is
if jenny was blindfolded
she would think that i'm
very she and aggie
about this point
my arm comes out
and i just end up a different shape
and she's blindfolded she didn't know
about the arm coming out there because
all she knows is she has the same
feeling
so she has the same feeling with one and
the other and that's how you start
piling your aikido techniques together
and you go oh yeah well that one feels
like that one and that one so you've got
to experience these popping in what
called oh this is the same one as that
one
are they painted all the worms the same
so this is how you build your ikey
though when
when they go god it's just too many
techniques to remember
there isn't as long as you
stick to the same format you go here and
she's not falling down oh i know what i
do i'll give her this to women
that's when they're individual
when you can get them
and bring your arms through and you're
the only person doing it then the only
difference is the arm
that's fine without touching
but that's being caught up in the same
energy i'm doing i'm doing exactly the
same
age
but i'm just doing short footwork
don't do that
okay so do it again the women hanging
shinagi should be experienced the same
to them but you're
doing this one hand
you're doing this two hands
there's lots of there's
too much
try some sheer nuggets try some more put
put them together and see if you can
make the only difference that last part
of the arm if they're not falling on the
sheer nagging
you shouldn't need their room and aggie
to secure it
okay so that's your goal